der bayerische ministerpräsident markus
söder der sich persönlich entschuldigt
hat es tue ihm persönlich leid diese
panel sieht aber keinen fehler bei sich
bei der staatskanzlei zur druck sei
nicht ausgeübt worden eine
gesundheitsministerin die zweimal ihren
rücktritt angeboten hat aber trotzdem
weiterhin im amt ist die panne hätte es
bei der ausführung nicht in der
strategie gegeben paul ronzheimer ist
das die richtige einschätzung des
ministerpräsidenten
ich denke nein denn natürlich hat die
strategie gelautet dass man diese tests
ganz ganz schnell will und das war die
strategie die von markus söder selbst
festgelegt wurde er wollte es sehr
schnell und er sagt ja auch zu recht
dass es gut ist wenn man auch dort nur
einen fall erkannt hat so erklärt er das
ja auch aber natürlich muss man sagen
dass die strategie so nicht funktioniert
hat das ist einmal ganz klar und ich
glaube da kann man auch nicht drum
herumreden dennoch hat markus söder
relativ klar gesagt dass es ihm leid tut
dass waren ungewöhnliche worte für den
bayerischen ministerpräsidenten er hat
gleichzeitig aber auch klar gemacht dass
das was bayern macht eben diese
kontrollen diese tests kein anderes
bundesland macht also hat die besondere
rolle
bayerns noch einmal hervorgehoben und er
hat dann mehrfach darauf hingewiesen
dass die gesundheitsministerien ihm ja
diesen rücktritt eben angeboten habe
zweimal sogar dass er das aber nicht
wollen sondern sich hier so sagt er
unterhaken will und dass er die leistung
der gesundheitsministerin nicht wegen
dieser einen panne bewerten will sondern
dass man eben in den vergangenen monaten
sehr eng zusammengearbeitet hat und auch
er weiterhin an sich glaubt er habe sie
dann gefragt ob sie denn glaubt dass sie
sozusagen das aussetzen kann dass das
nicht wieder passiert dass sie bereit
ist für diesen job dies habe sie bejaht
und deswegen wolle er an ihr festhalten
ich glaube am ende zahlt das ob sie das
konto ein ich glaube wenn er gesagt
hätte er
will dass sie zurücktritt oder sie sogar
feiert dann hätte das bedeutet noch viel
klarer er will die verantwortung so zu
sagen von sich weisen das hat er auch
betont in der pressekonferenz dass es
ihm da ihm wichtig ist da jetzt auch
selbst zu stehen nachdem es diese kritik
gegeben hat dass er dort nicht selbst
genug farbe bekennt und natürlich alle
dass vor dem hintergrund der möglichen
kanzlerkandidatur von markus söder da in
diese richtung gehen auch die meisten
fragen unserer zuschauer bei youtube was
bedeutet diese panne für mögliche
kanzler pläne von markus söder die panne
zeigt dass markus söder fehlbar ist in
der korona krise so wie übrigens alle
politiker fehlbar sind denn corona ist
unberechenbar das muss man einmal so
klar sagen aber markus söder ist
deswegen besonders viel bar oder
angreifbar wenn etwas passiert wenn ihm
ein fehler unterläuft weil er ebenso
häufig mit dem finger auf andere gezeigt
hat weil er gesagt hat schaut doch mal
nach einer weder gibt es ein hotspot da
ist karneval und dann passierte turniers
also insbesondere im rennen mit armin
laschet hat er sich immer sehr gefreut
wenn da fehler passiert sind das macht
einen politiker dann in so einer
situation besonders angreifbar und nicht
nur in der bevölkerung sondern natürlich
auch in der union in der union und
insbesondere bei der cdu der
schwesterpartei der csu wo man ohnehin
schon ein bisschen verstimmt war über
seinen auftritt mit angela merkel
herrenchiemsee wir erinnern uns an die
bilder dieser glamourösen bilder die er
fast schon wie eine kanzlerkandidaten
inszenierung gewirkt haben und da haben
schon viele in der cdu danach gesagt was
soll das eigentlich wieso macht er das
und was will er wirklich also ich glaube
schon das war ein dämpfer
jetzt für markus söders kommt jetzt sehr
auch darauf an wie das weitergeht gibt
es möglicherweise weitere enthüllungen
und auch die frage die ja unser kollege
unser bild kollege vor ort gestellt hat
was ist denn jetzt mit den infizierten
denn darauf konnte markus söder und
seine gesundheitsministerin an die die
frage dann gegen keine antwort geben
also wissen immer noch nicht wie viele
menschen jetzt informiert sind wir
wissen immer noch nicht wie viele
weitere menschen diejenigen infiziert
haben also es kann natürlich passieren
dass dieses thema und davon gehe ich aus
in den nächsten tagen noch weiter geht